can the emotion of awe unite us back
again that'd be great and I like the
idea I'm a little bit concerned that
something about modernity has made us
hard to impress yeah right that we are
all privy to the most extreme
demonstrations of capacity and beauty
and you know we've all been transported
to the most marvellous Beach on earth
you know which is further more than been
photoshopped right so yeah we all
imagined that the perfect beautiful
person and the perfect beautiful place
and the perfect beautiful everything is
not only something we've already
experienced even if we haven't but that
it's actually better than it is such
that when we do experience true
awesomeness in our lives we often don't
recognize it as such because it doesn't
live up to the unfolded
unperfect adverse of itself
yeah that said I do think that there are
things that will galvanize us or could
galvanize us and one of them I am hoping
is the possibility that there is a way
out of this that will in fact make us
feel good about ourselves again and I am
a little bit concerned that
unfortunately I find myself in trying to
write what that would be like it is very
hard for me to deal with the word hope
now because I feel that the Obama
administration was such a disappointment
in terms of what it accomplished that
many of us felt his hope we signed on
and then we're quickly disappointed it
has almost poisoned the concept of hope
and that leaves us grasping for synonyms
that are never as good this is
interesting I didn't know you were you
were thinking on this and I knew I know
what you're trying to write right now
but I actually went looking specifically
I was I was looking for something to
read at the end of the last hour that
would be hopeful
rather than
you know rather than so much else and I
must have you know a pile of ten books
downstairs all of which I think are
extraordinaire and I couldn't find
anything in the closest I came actually
but I don't I don't have something to
read from it was from Joseph Campbell
and I went to the hero with a thousand
faces in part because we were talking
about one of the things we were talking
about between this left live stream and
the last one was was the hero's journey
and trying to reveal to people that they
can take hold of that for themselves and
that in trying to face this thing down
it is not sufficient to take individual
action and yet it is in many cases the
only thing that is possible and well I
would like to propose something that we
didn't get to in depth today was a
deeper exploration of what what you do
when it comes knocking and maybe maybe
we want to do that next time we're yeah
I think we want to do it next time and
we want to take the time to do it do it
right
but there is something I do have the
sense that the world is a much a bigger
place than it was and the hero's journey
is simultaneously it contains a great
deal of truth but it also may be at the
wrong scale and so the question is can
we figure out how to scale it up to a
world with seven and a half billion
people on it that is simultaneously in
crisis and if you think about that it's
a frightening question but it's also
kind of a delightful opportunity and so
maybe that's where we are is we're
trying to bootstrap the the new twist on
the hero's journey because we need it
[Music]